Brady made three hundredth video for our
website and invited people to send us
pictures we've had quite a few already
this is my favorite one so far from the
school in Australia my wife fell about
laughing when she saw this picture of me
in front of somebody's face so we'd
really like you to send us some more
pictures but we'd particularly like it
to have you looking at the screen so we
can see that you really are periodic
video fans
this is another one I like is the
youngest fan we've got documented aged
18 months though the the picture of the
youngest viewer was a bit disturbing
there seemed to be a gun pointing at the
father's head we still don't know who
our oldest fan is so if you have
grandfather great-grandfather
great-grandmother or you are the great
grandmother yourself send us a picture
and there's a really strange one of
somebody whose profession is a contact
juggler has an atom rolling around his
head
you